ANNOUNCER: The following content
is provided under a
Creative Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or to view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
mitopencourseware@ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Hi.
Welcome once again to our
lectures in Calculus
Revisited, where today we are
going to talk about the
calculus of composite
functions.
Now, recall that we have already
mentioned in previous
lectures the notion of
a composite function.
And what we're going to do today
is to emphasize the idea
as to how often we are called
upon to find functional
relationships, where the first
variable is given in terms of
a second variable, and the
second variable, say, is given
in terms of the third
variable.
And we wish to find, say,
the first variable in
terms of the third.
Fact here is where the name "the
chain rule" seems to come
from, a chain reaction where the
variables are related in a
chain this way.
Now, we can see this quite
easily in terms of a diagram.
Suppose, for example,
that I have a graph
of 'x' versus 'y'.
And suppose also, I have a
graph of 't' versus 'x'.
Without any reference
to calculus--
and this is rather important--
without any reference to
calculus, notice that these
two graphs together allow
me to visualize
'y' in terms of 't'.
For example, given a particular
value of 't'--
let's call it 't sub 1'--
given a value of 't', from that
value of 't', I can find
the corresponding
value of 'x'.
Let's call that 'x sub 1'.
Now, knowing 'x sub 1', I can
come to this diagram.
Knowing what 'x sub 1' is,
I can find 'y sub 1'.
And so you see in this chain of
two diagrams, a particular
value of 't' allows me to find
a particular value of 'y'.
And in this particular way,
I can visualize 'y' as a
function of 't'.
And you see at this stage of the
game, there is absolutely
no need to have to have any
knowledge of calculus to
understand what it is that
we're discussing.
The place that calculus comes
in is in the following way.
Let's suppose it happened in
this first diagram that the
graph of 'y' versus
'x' was smooth.
In other words, let's assume
that 'y' is a differentiable
function of 'x'.
In particular, the way I've
drawn this diagram here, we're
saying suppose 'dy dx' evaluated
at 'x' equals 'x1'
happens to exist.
And suppose also that this graph
of 'x' versus 't', this
also happens to be a smooth
curve-- in other words, that
'x' is a differentiable
function of 't'.
Again, in the language of
calculus, what we're saying is
the slope of this curve exists
at this particular point, and
it's given by the 'x dt'
evaluated at 't' equals 't1'.
Now, without going into a proof
at this stage, all we're
saying is this.
We suspect that if 'y' is a
differentiable function of
'x', and 'x' is a differentiable
function of
't', that therefore, 'y'
should also be a
differentiable function
of 't'.
Notice it's not a conjecture
at all that if 'y' is a
function of 'x' and 'x' is a
function of 't', that 'y' is a
function of 't'.
That part is clear.
The conjecture is that we
suspect that if 'y' is a
differentiable function
of 'x', and 'x' is a
differentiable function of
't', that 'y' will be a
differentiable function
of 't'.
In still other words, our
suspicion is perhaps that a
differentiable function of a
differentiable function is
again a differentiable
function.
But even more to the point, not
only do we suspect, for
example, that the 'dy dt' exists
here when 't' equals
't1', but in line with our
lecture of last time, we might
even begin to suspect, in
terms of this fractional
notation, that not only does
the 'dy dt' exist at 't'
equals 't1', but it can be found
by multiplying 'dy dx'
evaluated at 'x' equals 'x1' by
the 'x dt' evaluated at 't'
equals 't1'.
Again, almost as if the 'dx'
from the numerator here
canceled with the 'dx' from the
denominator here, the same
as what we hope our
differential
notation would be.
The question is granted that
we would like a result like
this to hold true, in a course
such as calculus, where we're
working with very tiny numbers
and quotients of small
numbers, places where we've seen
that our intuition often
leads us astray, it becomes
fairly apparent that we had
better have something stronger
than just intuition in helping
us derive certain results, no
matter how natural these
results might look.
Now, the way we proceed here
is as follows again, and
notice again the building
blocks of calculus.
We go back to the fundamental
result of last time.
You see, after all, to find
'dy dt', we want 'delta y'
divided by 'delta t', and then
we'll take the limit as 'delta
t' approaches 0.
The question is, first of all,
do we have a nice expression
for 'delta y'?
And in terms of the lecture of
last time, we saw that if 'y'
was a differentiable function of
'x', that 'x' equals 'x1',
that 'delta y' was given by ''dy
dx', evaluated 'x' equals
'x1' times 'delta x'' plus
'k times delta x'--
and this is crucial now-- where
the limit of 'k' as
'delta x' approaches 0 was 0.
Now you see, this recipe
here is ironclad.
I emphasized it from a geometric
point of view last
time, but you may recall that I
proved it from an analytical
point of view.
In other words, whether you
want to visualize this or
derive it, it makes
no difference.
The key factors that this
statement here is ironclad.
It's something that we now
know to be true in our
so-called game of calculus.
The point is, again, now how do
we use this to check over
our conjectured result?
Again, the answer is almost
straightforward.
If you keep track of these
things, you'll notice that
calculus is a one-step-at-a-time
procedure.
Namely, we want 'dy dt'.
That suggests we first want
'delta y' divided by 'delta
t', and then we'll take
the limit as 'delta
t' approaches 0.
So first, we do this.
Namely, starting with our
known recipe, we divide
through by 'delta t', and
why can we do this?
We can do this because, of
course, 'delta t' is not 0.
Now we take the limit of both
sides of the equality as
'delta t' approaches 0.
We observe that on the left-hand
side, the limit of
'delta y' divided by 'delta t',
as 'delta t' approaches 0,
is precisely 'dy dt', and
in this particular case,
evaluated at 't' equals 't1'.
In other words, notice that the
left-hand side here, as we
let 'delta t' approach 0,
becomes the left-hand side of
our conjecture.
Now we recall again that the
limit of the sum is the sum of
the limits, and we now take
the limit of each of these
terms separately, each
term as a product.
The limit of a product is the
product of the limits.
'dy dx' evaluated at 'x' equals
'x1' is a constant.
In fact, that's just
what, it's 'dy'.
The limit of 'dy dx' evaluated
'x' equals 'x1', as 'delta t'
approaches 0, is just 'dy dx'
evaluated 'x' equals 'x1'.
On the other hand, by
definition, the limit of
'delta x' divided by 'delta t',
as 'delta t' approaches 0,
is just 'dx dt'.
And keeping track of the
subscripts here, later on
we'll become sloppy and leave
the subscripts out.
There really is no great
harm done in
calculus of a single variable.
We shall find, in calculus of
several variables, that it is
extremely important to keep
track of the subscripts and
where the variables are being
evaluated and things of this
particular type.
But I just want to get you used
to the fact that these
are specific numbers that
we're using over here.
Now let's continue.
We take the limit of this term
as 'delta t' approaches 0.
We observe that this becomes 'dx
dt', and the limit of 'k'
as 'delta t' approaches 0--
well, as 'delta t' approaches
0, the fact that 'x' is a
differentiable function of
't' means that 'delta x'
approaches 0.
And since the limit of 'k' as
'delta x' approaches 0 is 0,
this term becomes 0.
0 times anything is, any
finite number, is 0.
That means that this term here
in the limit becomes 0, and
we're left with the
desired result.
But notice that we did not
arrive at this desired result
by hand waving.
We did not say this term 'delta
x' is getting small, so
it's becoming negligible.
I can't emphasize this point
enough that it is true that
'delta x' is becoming small
here, but so is 'delta t', and
that indicates, essentially,
you're 0 over 0 form.
And the thing that saves us,
the thing that makes this
whole term drop out, is the key
fact that 'k' itself goes
to 0, as 'delta x' goes to 0.
By the way, there are easier
ways of intuitively trying to
remember the chain rule.
For example, one way that people
often try to visualize
the chain rule is this.
They'll say, OK, we
want 'dy dt'.
So let's take 'delta y' divided
by 'delta t', and then
we'll take the limit as 'delta
t' approaches 0.
Now, you see in this notation
here, 'delta y' and 'delta t'
are actually numbers.
As numbers, we can write these
things in fractional notation,
and we could write, what, that
'delta y' divided by 'delta t'
is ''delta y' divided by 'delta
x'' times ''delta x'
divided by 'delta t''.
Then we could take the limit,
as delta t approaches 0, and
we would arrive at
the same result.
But again, without trying
to make this thing too
obnoxiously long here, the thing
to keep in mind is that
'x' is a function of 't'.
And from a rigorous point of
view, the danger with this
shortcut technique--
and it can be patched up but
requires a great deal of
mathematical analysis--
the danger here is that as
'delta t' approaches 0, it's
quite possible that 'delta
x' will be 0.
In other words, it's possible
that for a given change in
't', there is no
change in 'x'.
Now, if 'delta x' happens to
equal 0, then we're in
trouble over here.
In other words, in many cases,
this shortened version gives
us an idea as to what's
going on.
But our so-called longer method
has no pitfalls to it.
But enough said for what
this recipe is.
This result is known as the
chain rule, and this will be
the topic of the rest
of today's lecture.
Now, let's take a look at
some of these things
in a bit more detail.
For example, let's look
at an illustration.
Suppose we want to find 'dy dx',
if 'y' is equal to ''x
squared + 1' squared'.
Let me first do this problem
the wrong way.
Let's put a question
mark over here.
People learn things like, what,
bring the exponent down
and replace it by one less.
Now certainly, if I bring the
exponent down here, and
replace it by one less, this
is the answer that I get.
Of course the question is,
is this the right answer?
Well, you see, notice one very
nice way about finding out
whether an answer is wrong, is
to first find out by another
way which is the right answer.
For example, if 'y' equals ''x
squared + 1' squared', it
happens that we know how
to square this thing.
We can find directly
that another way of
expressing 'y' is what?
It's 'x' to the fourth plus '2x
squared' plus 1, but we
have previously learned how to
differentiate a polynomial.
Through the polynomial is what,
this is going to be
what? '4 x cubed' plus '4x'.
And you see somehow or other,
this does not seem to give--
well, for one thing, we
see that these are
two different answers.
For another thing, if this is
the one that happens to be the
right answer, this is the one
that is the wrong answer.
And since we know from previous
material this is the
right answer, there is something
wrong with this
regardless of how right
it might look.
In fact, how much are
we off by over here?
If we factor this thing
out, what can we do?
We can write this as '4x'
times 'x squared + 1'.
And what we really had
over here was twice
'x squared + 1'.
It seems that the correction
factor is '2x'.
Now again, notice that the
derivative of what's inside
the parentheses over here just
happens to be exactly '2x'.
Now how does the chain rule
come into play in a
problem of this type?
You see, the thing is, that what
we should do over here is
rewrite this.
Namely, for example, let 'u'
equal 'x squared + 1'.
Then what this says is what? 'y'
is equal to 'u squared',
where 'u' is equal to
'x squared + 1'.
This is just another way of
writing this, and in this
particular form, the
chain rule seems to
be emphasized more.
You see, 'y' is a function of
'u', 'u' is a function of 'x'.
Notice that from the first
equation, it is relatively
easy to find 'dy du'.
In fact, it's just what, '2u'.
We'll write that down later.
From the second equation, it's
easy to find 'du dx'.
And by the chain rule, all we're
saying is that 'dy du'
times 'du dx' is 'dy dx'.
See, what will that give
us in this case?
'dy du' is '2u'.
'du dx' is '2x'.
That gives us '4x' times 'u'.
'u' is 'x squared + 1', and so
this becomes '4x' times 'x
squared + 1'.
And if we now compare this
with what was the correct
answer, we see that
in this case,
everything worked out fine.
I suppose what we should do here
is to comment now on the
danger of memorizing recipes
without thoroughly
understanding them.
The idea, that said when you
want to differentiate
something raised to a power that
you bring the power down
and replace it by one less,
hinged on the fact that the
thing that was being raised
to the power was the same
variable with respect to which
you were doing the
differentiation.
You see, for example, when we
had 'y' equaled 'x squared',
and then we wrote that 'dy dx'
is '2x', the thing that was
important over here was
the fact that what?
The thing that was being raised
to the second power is
precisely the variable with
respect to which we were doing
the differentiation.
You see, in the problem 'y'
equals 'x squared + 1'
squared, the thing that was
being raised to the second
power was 'x squared + 1'.
The variable with respect
to which we were
differentiating was 'x'.
In other words, to write this
thing more symbolically, if
'y' is equal to something,
square it, then the derivative
that's equal to twice that
something is the derivative of
'y' with respect to
that something.
You see, the place the chain
rule comes in is when the
variable which appears here,
is not the same as the
variable which appears here, and
we'll see this in greater
detail as we go along.
By the way, the chain rule comes
up in another form known
as parametric equations, and
this form comes up very often.
It's a twist of what we were
talking about before.
This is the situation in which
frequently we want to compare
two variables.
Let's call them 'x' and
'y', all right?
And it happens that both
variables, 'x' and 'y', can be
expressed more simply in terms
of a third variable, 't'.
And frequently, what one does
is try to talk about the
relationship that exists between
'y' and 'x' in terms
of eliminating t between
these two equations.
By the way, in terms of
differential language, there
seems to be an easier way
of handling this.
Namely, you see, if we
differentiate the first
equation, we get what, that
'dy dt' is 'f prime of t'.
If we differentiate the second
equation, we get that 'dx dt'
is 'g prime of t'.
Now if, as we said in our last
lecture, we can pretend that
this is really a fraction,
that it's
'dy' divided by 'dt'--
in other words, if we think of
'dy' as being 'delta y-tan',
of 'dx' as being 'delta x-tan',
and 'dt' as being
'delta t', it would appear that
we could say, what, that
'dy dt' divided by 'dx dt'
would just be what?
'dy dx'.
In other words, ''dy' divided
by 'dt'' divided by ''dx'
divided by 'dt'', which is what
this would say if this
was in differential form,
would just be 'dy dx'.
In other words, we get the
feeling that to find the
derivative here, all we have
to do is differentiate 'y'
with respect to 't', and divide
that by the derivative
of 'x' with respect to 't'.
And by the way, you see, this
becomes a particularly
powerful tool in those
computational cases where we
do not know how to eliminate
't', and to solve specifically
for 'y' in terms of 'x'.
You see, in terms of this
particular recipe over here,
we are allowed to leave 'x'
and 'y' in terms of 't'.
Again, the same old bugaboo
comes up to plague us.
The fact that something seems
natural is not enough to allow
us to believe that it's
actually correct.
Is there a more rigorous way of
obtaining the same result?
Again, the answer is yes.
And not only is the answer yes,
but it goes back to the
fundamental recipe that we
were discussing in our
previous lecture.
Namely, we know that 'delta y'
is ''f prime of t' times
'delta t'' plus 'k1 delta t',
and the 'delta x' is ''g prime
of t' times 'delta t'' plus 'k2
delta t', where both the
limit of 'k1' and 'k2' as
'delta t' approach 0.
And this is a notation, I think,
that takes a while to
get used to.
We're used to seeing letters
like 'k' stand for constants,
but it's important over here
to understand that 'k1' and
'k2' are functions of 'delta
t', that the difference
between 'delta y' and 'delta
y-tan', 'delta x' and 'delta
x-tan', that difference, which
is 'k delta x' or 'k delta y',
depending on which problem
we're dealing with that's
certainly 'k' in that case, does
depend on how big 'delta
t' happens to be.
At any rate, the important thing
is that as 'delta t'
approaches 0, these
go to 0 also.
Now you see if we take this, and
actually compute 'delta y'
divided by 'delta x'--
and we'll write this a little
bit more suggestively, factor
out 'delta t' from both
numerator and denominator--
it rigorously tells us what
'delta y' divided
by 'delta x' is.
Now we take the limit, as
'delta x' approaches 0.
That, by definition, is what?
That's by definition 'dy dx'.
Well, you see, first of all,
we cancel out the 'delta t'
over here, see, 'delta t' is
not 0, we're assuming.
Since it's not 0 it can be
canceled out, and once we've
canceled out 'delta t', notice
that as 'delta t' approaches
0, so does 'delta x'.
As 'delta x' approaches
0, so does 'delta t'.
That makes 'k1' and
'k2' go to 0.
And then since the limit of a
quotient is the quotient of
the limits, provided only the
'g prime of t' is not 0, we
see that in the eliminating
process, we
get the same answer.
And by the way, see, once we
get the same answer, as we
would have got the short way,
then we can use the
convenience of the
short recipe.
However, the fact that the short
recipe was nice is not
enough of a guarantee
that it was giving
us the correct answer.
As a case in point, it's rather
interesting to point
out that if you want the
second derivative--
in other words, let's recall
what we have here.
We have what? 'y' was given
to 'b', say 'f of t'.
'x' was given by 'g of t'.
And you see from these two
equations, what we
could do is find what?
We could find the second
derivative of 'y with respect
to t', and we could also find
from this equation the second
derivative of 'x' with
respect to 't'.
This we could certainly do.
And mechanically, we could
certainly say, let's cancel
the common denominator.
The interesting thing is that
when you form that quotient,
whatever that quotient is, it
does not come out to be the
second derivative of 'y'
with respect to 'x'.
And there is an interesting
piece of folklore over here.
I don't know if this ever
bothered you or not, but it
used to bother me.
I never understood why, when
you talk about the second
derivative, that the exponent
was written between the 'd'
and the variable in one case,
but written at the end in the
other case.
In other words, notice that the
2 here appears between the
'd' and the 'y', but
in the denominator,
the 'd' appears outside.
And again, it was the foresight
of the fathers of
differential calculus who
noticed rather interestingly
that if mechanically you did
agree to cancel the common
denominator here, that what you
would wind up with is not
'd2y dx squared',
but rather what?
'd2y d2x'.
In other words, if you
mechanically carried this out,
notice that the notation
would be incorrect.
The 2 comes out to be in the
wrong place over here.
You see, again, the interesting
point is we don't
have to rely on taking
my word for it.
Somebody might say to me, now
look, all you've told me is
that I get the wrong answer
solving this problem this
particular way.
And you've given me a nice
lecture about how the 2's come
out the wrong way
and everything.
How do I know that this
is the wrong answer?
See, and again, everything
comes back to
fundamentals again.
To find 'd2y dx squared',
observe that by definition,
that's just 'd dx' of 'dy dx'.
That definition doesn't depend
on what functions we're
dealing with.
The second derivative with
respect to 'x' is the
derivative with respect to 'x'
of the first derivative.
Now, once we have this, you see,
knowing from our previous
case, that what?
'dy dx' was 'f prime of t'
divided by 'g prime of t'.
We can now do what?
Take this derivative.
By the way, again, notice
how the chain
rule comes up in practice.
It's not always dictated
to us.
If you look at the expression
inside the parentheses, what
do we have?
Inside the parentheses, we have
a function of 't' only.
This is a function of 't'.
We want to differentiate
it with respect to 'x'.
The most natural variable to
differentiate a function of
't' with respect to
is 't' itself.
In other words, what would've
been nice is if this was the
derivative of 'f prime of t'
over 'g prime of t', with
respect to 't'.
See, this would be
easier to handle.
We would then use the quotient
rule, et cetera.
You see, we can differentiate
a function of 't'
with respect to 't'.
The trouble is we have
the derivative
with respect to 'x'.
And if we just change this to
a 't', that's cheating.
See, I mean, you pretend you
copy it wrong, because it's an
easier problem to
solve that way.
The beauty of the chain rule is
that it allows us to do the
problem the easier way, and
to doctor up the resulting
incorrect answer by
the right answer.
Namely, you see what we wanted
to wind up with here is what,
the derivative not with respect
to 't', but with
respect to 'x'.
And so, by using the chain
rule, you see we do what?
We take the derivative with
respect to 't', multiply that
by 'dt dx'--
again, mechanically, almost
as if these canceled.
But this is the way the chain
rule works, and now, you see,
I can work this out by
the regular quotient
rule, which says what?
It's the denominator times the
derivative of the numerator.
See, and I am differentiating
out respect to 't', the
natural variable, minus the
numerator times the derivative
of the denominator over the
square of the denominator.
Now, that's a mess by itself,
meaning, what,
computationally, it's
not that obvious.
I mean, it's quite a bit of work
to do here, and then that
whole thing must be multiplied
by 'dt dx'.
And this, you see, is how one
goes around finding the second
derivative of 'y' with respect
to 'x' in terms
of parametric equations.
And more than once, if you're
not careful, you're going to
find yourself making serious
mistakes, by forgetting to put
in this factor of 'dt dx'.
By the way, an interesting
point is that we have not
computed 'dt dx'.
We have computed 'dx dt'.
Let's go back here.
See, 'x' was 'g of t'.
So from that, 'dx dt'
is 'g prime of t'.
And the question is if 'dx dt'
is 'g prime of t', how does
one find 'dt dx'?
And again, I think your
intuition is going to tell you
to just take reciprocals.
And again, the question is it's
true that this suggests
taking reciprocals, but how do
we know that we can do this,
and if we can do this, what
does it really mean?
You see, what this is leading
into is what's going to be the
subject of our lecture next
time, called 'Inverse
Functions'.
And just to give you a preview
of what that lecture is about,
and how we work things like
this, let's take a look at
what we mean by inverse
functions.
Well, we won't even mention
it in much detail.
But let's take a look and see
what's going on over here.
Let's suppose that the first--
and by the way, I've started to
abandon using the 't' over
here all the time.
I think those of us in
engineering work primarily
keep thinking of 't' as being
time, and you may get the
mistaken notion that if the
variable isn't time, the thing
doesn't work this way.
In most cases, physically, the
variable that we're interested
in will be time.
But just for the idea of getting
you used to the fact
that it makes no difference what
the name of the variable
is, I've taken the liberty
of writing this slightly
differently.
Namely, I now assume that y is
a differentiable function of
'u', and that 'u' is a
differentiable function of 'x'.
By the chain rule, I now know
that 'y' is a differentiable
function of 'x', and that 'dy
dx' is 'dy du' times 'du dx'.
The interesting thing here is,
is that there is nothing in
the statement of the chain rule
that says that the first
variable in the third that
'x' and 'y' must
be different variables.
In fact, it might happen that
'x' and 'y' are synonyms for
one another.
If 'x' and 'y' happen
to be synonyms--
suppose 'x' and 'y'
are synonyms--
look what happens over here.
'dy dx' is then just 'dy
dy', which is 1.
See, let's write that down.
That's 'dy dy'.
This would be 'dy du', and
if 'x' is equal to
'y', this is 'du dy'.
And if this is equal to 1, and
this is 'dy du', and this is
'du dy', what does this tell
us about the relationship
between 'dy du' and 'du dy'?
It says their product is 1.
And if the product is 1, that
by definition means that the
two factors are reciprocals.
Now, what I want you to observe
over here is what this
whole thing means.
Namely, if 'y' happens to equal
'x', do you see what
this thing says?
It says that 'y' is a
differentiable function of
'u', and 'u' in turn is a
differentiable function of 'y'.
That's precisely what we
meant when we talked
about inverse functions.
We don't know when an inverse
function exists.
All we're saying is, is that
if 'f inverse' happens to
exist over here, to find 'du
dy', all we have to do is take
the reciprocal of 'dy du'.
Now again, this is
going to be the
subject of our next lecture.
All I wanted to do was to make
this aside for the time being.
What I want to do to complete
today's lecture is to get to
something more tangible.
See, now that we've talked about
the chain rule, we've
talked about inverse functions a
little bit, and talked about
these things from a highly
theoretical point of view,
let's go ahead and
try to solve a
particularly simple problem.
By particularly simple,
I mean this.
I have chosen the numbers to
come out in a very, very easy
way, so we don't get lost
in the maze of details.
In other words, there was a
danger that we will confuse
the computational details
with the theory.
So to emphasize the theory,
I've tried to pick a
straightforward simple problem,
but let's see how
this thing works out.
Let's suppose that we're given
that 'y' is equal to 't to the
fourth power', and 'x' is
equal to 't squared'.
What we would like to do-- and
by the way, notice what this
thing says, a given value of 't'
determines both an 'x' and
the 'y', so that makes 'x' and
'y' functionally related.
Notice that from the first
equation, we can find that 'dy
dt' is '4 t cubed'.
From the second equation, we can
find that 'dx dt' is '2t'.
And if we now use the chain
rule, 'dy dx' will be what?
It'll be 'dy dt' divided
by 'dx dt', and
that's just '2 t squared'.
By the way, as a check,
notice this.
If 'y' is equal to 't to the
fourth', and 'x' is equal to
't squared', since 't to the
fourth' is the square of 't
squared', that says 'y' is
equal to ''t squared'
squared', 'y' is equal
to 'x squared'.
And if 'y' is equal to 'x
squared', in this case, it's
very easy to see that 'dy
dx' is equal to '2x'.
By the way, when we try to
compare these two answers,
they look different, but
that's because they're
expressed in terms of
different variables.
If we return to our original
equations, and we see that 'x'
is equal to 't squared'--
'x' is a synonym for
't squared'--
this is the check that we have
received the right answer.
By the way, before I conclude
today's lecture, I would like
to make a rather
important aside
about parametric equations.
After one works the problem this
way, and comes down to
the check, and says, hey, after
all of this mess over
here, I could have replaced
it by just 'y' equals 'x
squared', why did I have
to work with this
in the first place?
We are going to have many, many
examples throughout the
course that will illustrate
this.
But at least once in a lecture,
I would like to go on
record as pointing out that this
pair of equations tells
you much more than this
equation here.
This equation simply
tells you this.
If a particle were moving along
a curve with respect to
time according to these
equations, this equation here
simply tells you what path the
particle would follow.
Namely, the parabola 'y'
equals 'x squared'.
On the other hand, these
two equations tell you
much more than that.
These not only tell you that the
particle moved along the
parabola 'y' equals 'x squared',
but rather, it tells
you at a particular time the
point on the parabola that the
particle was at.
What I mean is this.
As another example, suppose we
had 'y' equals 't squared,'
and 'x' equals 't'.
If we eliminate 't' from these
two equations, we also find
that 'y' is equal
to 'x squared'.
Yet notice that this is not the
same as our original set
of equations.
For example, here, when 't' is
2, when 't' is 2 over here,
what point are we on as far as
the parabola is concerned?
When 't' is 2, this is
2, and this is 4.
That would be the
point 2 comma 4.
On the other hand, with respect
to this equation, when
't' is 2, 'x' is 4, and 'y' is
16, you see both of these
particles would follow the same
curve, but they are at
different points at
different times.
So don't belittle the
parametric approach.
Having the parameter 't' in
there tells you more than just
what the path of
the motion is.
It tells you at what time
a particle was at what
particular point.
Well, enough about that.
Let's go ahead and find the
second derivative now.
You see, we already know that
'dy dx' is '2 t squared'.
Now what we'd like to find
is 'd2y dx squared'.
Again, the same basic
definition.
'd2y dx squared'.
The second derivative is the
derivative of the first
derivative.
The first derivative we saw was
'2 t squared', so this is
the derivative of
'2 t squared'.
Again, and this is where most
of the mistakes are made,
people get sloppy.
They forget the 'x'
is in here.
They say I know the derivative
of this, it's '4t'.
Well, the derivative of this is
'4t' with respect to 't'.
We want to differentiate
with respect to 'x'.
And the way the chain rule comes
in, we say OK, since 't'
is the natural variable with
respect to which to
differentiate, let's do it.
We'll differentiate
in respect to 't'.
But since the final answer has
to be with respect to 'x', our
correction factor by the chain
rule will be 'dt dx'.
Well, the derivative of '2 t
squared' with respect to 't'
is clearly '4t'.
The derivative of 't' with
respect to 'x', assuming that
we know something about inverse
functions, that's the
reciprocal of 'dx dt'.
We just saw that 'dx
dt' was '2t'.
Therefore, 'dt dx' is 1 over
'2t', and therefore, the
correct answer appears
to be 2.
Again, this is why I picked
the simple case.
Given that 'y' equals 'x
squared', we see at a glance
that 'dy dx' is equal to '2x',
and also at a glance,
therefore, that 'd2y dx squared'
is equal to 2.
By the way, that's exactly
what this is equal to.
You see, had we forgot the chain
rule, and had we left
this factor out, this would
have given us--
in other words, to simply write
down that the answer was
'4t', which is the most common
mistake that's made, would
have given us the
wrong answer.
That's why I put such
an easy problem.
You see, if I had picked a
tougher computational problem,
the theory would have
remained the same.
But when I got two different
answers, it would have been
difficult to determine which
was the correct answer, and
which was the incorrect
answer.
But again, to summarize today's
lecture, it was a
continuation in a way of the
lecture of last time, when we
developed the primary recipe
involving differentials.
Now we applied that
to find something
called the chain rule.
In the process of emphasizing
the chain rule, we talked
about the necessity of
knowing something
about inverse functions.
Consequently, that dictates what
our next lecture will be
concerned with, namely
inverse functions.
And so until next
time, goodbye.
ANNOUNCER: Funding for the
publication of this video was
provided by the Gabriella and
Paul Rosenbaum Foundation.
Help OCW continue to provide
free and open access to MIT
courses by making a donation
at ocw.mit.edu/donate.